we all know that a good story can move
us make us feel something teach us
something help us be better at something
but can a story literally move us
that is get us to move and be healthy
today we'll learn the answer to this
question and many other best practices
for what makes a good story
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
we are so lucky today to be joined by
paula moya paula is the dani and laura
louise bell professor of the humanities
and a professor of english at stanford
she also is a recipient of the dean's
award for distinguished teaching
paula has several books on the market
the most recent being the social
imperative race close reading and
contemporary literary criticism for the
past two years she's been part of a
research project that investigates and
validates using narrative to encourage
individuals to increase their activity
levels to improve health span
welcome paulo i am so eager to work with
you thank you matt i'm so glad to be
here and to have an opportunity to chat
with you
great let's get started
before we get into some of the really
cool ways you're using stories to
motivate people i'd like to start with
some general questions about stories
you are a narratologist
i've never heard that term before can
you define what that means and what do
you do
well
narratology uh basically it's just the
study of narratives and narrative
structure and the ways that these things
affect human perception so a
neurotologist basically is just someone
who does the studying
you know i've always loved reading and
i'm captivated by stories and so it's
been my pleasure over the last decade or
so
to be able to spend time
thinking about what makes narratives
work wow a whole field i was unaware of
so as somebody who studied narratives as
deeply as you have i'm curious from your
perspective what makes a good narrative
or story i guess i'd have to say that a
lot depends on what anyone means by good
right so
um
i love many different kinds of stories
and i know that they all draw on
different kinds of elements to give them
their value but the basic elements of a
story we can start there of a story or a
narrative or plot so like what happens
characters
points of view or perspective and that
relates to focalization
shedding like where it's located theme
kind of basically what they're talking
about of course style
so conflict is also central to any story
because there always needs to be
something that kind of gets the story
going and powers the events that occur
so these elements will always be present
in any particular story albeit in
different combinations and with
different emphases
so um you know a good story or narrative
will have all of those
but it's important to know from my
perspective that what one person defines
as good may be very different from what
some other person defines as good
so what good is will be very much
influenced by what someone knows what
they value what they love and also what
they recognize
and this is sometimes cultural right
based on where someone grew up
what they are accustomed to doing in
their daily lives
and it's also sometimes learned right
based on uh what we're taught in school
right what did our teachers tell us or
even what someone we admire says is good
so maybe a preacher or a mother or an
act
so for example those of us who read a
lot of uh stories or consume a lot of
narratives and so i i count myself among
women sure i'm always
reading or watching some cereal or
something you know when we do that we
can easily become bored by characters
that we perceive as stock characters or
plots that are predictable you know if
you read enough narratives you you start
to recognize certain particular terms
and and and we get bored by them because
we've seen them too many times before
and they contain for us no surprises
at the same time for someone else that
same story can be fresh and interesting
so my answer kind of to like what's good
what makes a good narrative is that a
story is good if someone somewhere
values it as good
now it just might not be good for me
so and i'm making a larger point about
the existence of multiple conceptions of
the good certainly
i hear you talking about several things
for example
you need to think about who your story
is for and what's going to be
interesting relevant and exciting for
them
and you need to be careful i heard also
of falling into the trap of of using
common cliches or common
uh ways of of telling the story or
designing the story i heard you talk
about surprise i heard you talk about a
novelty or at least i'm applying novelty
to what you said to really make it
something that stands out would you
agree with those i would completely
agree with that so it's kind of a mix
of making it familiar which we like just
as human beings psychologically we we
have a kind of principle of familiarity
that uh that drives us and also making
it new making it a little surprising
giving us something that is not
predictable so um but it kind of goes
back to the first thing that you picked
up on which is that we always have to
think about who this narrative is for
because it's going to be you know what's
going to work is going to be different
according to who it's for absolutely and
that is a theme we have heard many times
on this podcast about really reflecting
on our audience for our communication
should we approach crafting stories
meant to be read
differently from those that we speak
absolutely i really agree with that
because you know it is if you're if
you're listening to a story you might
need a heavier dose of repetition
to help your you know listener keep
track of what is happening and so you
see this in sort of storytelling
cultures where there's often a great
deal of repetition and they come back to
certain kinds of motifs
so like a certain image or a certain
color and you know if you're listening
to a story you can't go back and look
something up right so you need the
storyteller to help you by drawing you
along with these repeated motifs these
repeated words and also reminders of who
is who and how they are related to other
characters
and i think it's probably a little
easier to have a more complex
narrative in writing than listening i
really want to emphasize this point in
the work that i do
there's a really big challenge that
people have they write as if they're
writing their content to be read and
then they speak it and it just sounds
different it doesn't connect in the same
way
a lot of the ideas that you suggested
those are all things that can really
help a story stand out when spoken
and similarly might
seem redundant or repetitive or
short-sighted in a written piece so the
the big message is we have to envision
writing for
speaking and writing for being read as
very different things and and i think
that point is super important it
absolutely is and i'm glad that you are
articulating it so clearly i i need to
learn from that
no i i well i do a lot of speaking so i
repeat myself a lot much to my family's
dismay
but let me just say one more thing about
that is that um always when we're
thinking about communicating we need to
think about the medium like so how is it
that we are you know what is the medium
through which we are communicating so
obviously a novel is a different medium
than say you know a story circle where
you're sitting around talking to people
the medium really that it makes it so
important to sort of shift how you do
something if you want to communicate
well
so true i cannot tell you the number of
times i see people try to tell stories
through bullet points on powerpoint
slides and
it's it's the wrong medium it's the
wrong tool to get your message across
and and i i really appreciate that
advice
i'd like to turn to your research your
research and writings focus on race and
culture
do you have any guidance on how we can
be more inclusive of diversity in the
stories we choose to tell and and how we
actually craft those stories
well i think probably the easiest way
the most simple
way to be inclusive diversity is also
the most obvious way
that is to write or consume stories
about those people places events and
dilemmas that are for the most part
absent or underrepresented in the
mainstream of society
so they're not for example sufficient
representations of latinx people in the
media
television theater the movies in
journalism to give a true and accurate
picture of the richness and the
complexity of latino life
this is not to say that there is none
just to say that there is a dearth of
such representation relative to the
number of latinx people living in this
country
and unfortunately many of the
representations of latinx people are
quite negative and stereotypical and so
not representative of the wide range of
experiences of people who are associated
with that ethnicity so it certainly
sounds to me like
if you're looking to be more inclusive
in the stories you tell you need to tell
stories that include people that that by
definition i think is is what we're
talking about but we also have to be
sensitive to what we represent and what
we talk tell those stories about so it's
not just including
people in the stories it's what those
stories are about and the focus and what
they
the message they send beyond the story
itself and and that's really important
for all of us to think about as we live
in a more diverse culture it's critical
to hear the stories and voices of
everyone you are part of a very cool
interdisciplinary team looking at the
role of narrative in motivating positive
health behavior
can you tell us briefly about the
perfecto project
so the perfecto project is actually an
extension of a larger project involving
a very large interdisciplinary team at
stanford university
that has been researching the
effectiveness in motivating mobility of
narrative-based feedback that is
delivered on the ambient screen of an
android smartphone so basically that
just means it's a mobility app that
helps take the user through a
narrative and as the user exercises or
walks or does some kind of physical
activity the story moves along so they
help power the story in that sense it
sounds to me like it's a fitness tracker
the the data from which actually moves
you through a story and that story
serves to help motivate even more
movement is that right that's exactly
right and so what we're trying to do is
create a narrative that's interesting
enough that the person wants to do their
exercise so they can get the next
chapter wow
i think for the listeners this notion of
thinking about creating stories that you
share as a leader as a participant of
teams that are culturally relevant
and the fact that you are finding that
the notion that a story can serve as
motivation for any behavior potentially
is really a fascinating one as part of
the work you just described
i read that there seems to be a link
between motivation and empathy for
characters and stories
can you describe this association and
any guidance that it might suggest for
those of us trying to motivate others
through the stories we tell
well i do think empathy where we feel
for others as well as things like
recognition where we maybe see
characters that remind us of ourselves
are very important for how stories
affect listeners and readers because one
very basic psychological phenomenon is
familiarity which is simply a form of
remembering and with a situation an
event a person a place or the like
provokes a subjective feeling of
recognition so if i guess
you know i've been at that uh tamale
making party i've been at that uh
birthday party where you know there's
where we break a pinata so it doesn't
have to be perfect but it it brings
something
of ourselves to us
and i think being recognized makes us
feel good feel valued it makes us feel a
sense of belonging
this notion of helping people
feel what what you're talking about is
familiar to them is really interesting
it really speaks to the need to
demonstrate that you understand people's
experience and and help them
see
how they can change that experience
enhance that experience etc so this
notion of using empathy
to demonstrate familiarity i think is a
really interesting tool for
those of us who craft communications to
have in our toolkit
do you have a favorite tool that you
listen for or look for in what you write
or you read for example i do i love
alliteration i'm curious do you have any
tools you you find
that you gravitate towards in narratives
that you write or listen to
you know that's a very interesting
question i'm not sure that i think of it
as programmatically as that like oh
these are my tools but i definitely use
alliteration i find it very effective so
a
modicum of repetition
alliteration i will often uh speak my
written sentences aloud to see how they
sound to me um
and then of course thinking about images
i'm very attentive to the use of certain
words and also not reinforcing
uh certain associations that have been
negative for instance for people of
color
the tools you shared are really helpful
for all of us to think about
before we get to our closing i am
curious if you have any last best
practices on how to craft better stories
to motivate our audiences
clearly an author or storyteller needs
to create compelling situations uh and
dilemmas full of suspense and surprise
because those are things that give us
joy they also need to create characters
in whom we are interested
whether it be because the characters if
we see ourselves in them or because we
care about them or feel empathy for them
or because they operate in a field of
action that in some way intrigues us
maybe even scares us
before we end i'd like to ask you the
same three questions i ask everybody
sound okay
yeah sure
all right if you were to capture the
best communication advice you ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title
what would it be
make them want to turn the page oh i
really like that it is an eight word
sentence i think but you know if you're
reading a novel like you want to know
either because the character or the
situation whatever you want to know
what's going to happen absolutely it's
building suspense and intrigue and and
that's important in all communication
let me ask you question number two who
is the communicator that you admire and
why
i would say that margaret atwood is an
amazing communicator
she is an amazing novelist i eagerly
seek out anything she writes she is a
beautiful user of language she could
make me
envision
the the world that she was putting
together and she wasn't she also was not
afraid to make difficult characters who
are
real in the sense that people like them
exist out there in the world
our final question what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
i'd say sense like that that the story
has to make sense
uh humor
and then finally suspense and that comes
from like making them want to turn the
page
i i like this notion of it it just has
to make sense right a lot of us don't
take a simple criterion like that uh
we've definitely on this podcast talked
about humor and the value of humor and
and you've illuminated today how
suspense and familiarity can be really
really helpful
um paula thank you so much for joining
us today and sharing the story of your
work and how to make our stories work
better
we're taking away so many important
insights that can really strengthen our
narratives and and help us motivate
people in the direction that we want i
appreciate your time and your insights
thank you
well thank you matt i'm very happy to
have had the chance to talk with you
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford.gsb